Oh,
good morning.
We can start and today we'll be discussing poliomyelitis or polio for short.
And you may be wondering why we've included it at this point,
uh,
late in the day on our course.
And that's because a number of you have been saying that they,
you'd like to have the course come right up today.
And today's newspapers and where I want to deal with polio,
um,
I hope is in light of that request.
In other words,
we're going to be dealing with polio,
uh,
at this very moment.
And in particular with problems of vaccination that very major public health
strategy,
the subject will really be the problems facing the global polio eradication
initiative,
which just to remember and remind you,
is the largest public health campaign ever launched.
It predicted global eradication by 2000 and when it began in 1988,
it used as its model the eradication of smallpox,
as you know,
pioneered long ago by Edward Jenner and actually reaching successful conclusion
in 1980 when the World Health Organization certified that the warm glow glow was
free of naturally occurring smallpox.
There seem to be a number of reasons that smallpox could be taken as the model.
This was the first disease and still the only one major disease actually
eradicated intentionally by human beings by a public health campaign.
It was thought that polio had a number of features that it made it a similarly
good candidate,
just like smallpox.
It was a disease like smallpox that possessed no animal reservoir,
so if you got rid of it in the human population,
it wouldn't again jump species and recur through transmission from animals to
humans.
It was also a viral disease and the pathogen has no complicated life cycle.
It's at the other end of the spectrum from,
for example,
the malaria plasmodium,
the acquired resistance is robust,
produced by the body.
Naturally that was true of polio as it is of smallpox.
And it was the case that just as in the example of smallpox,
so too with polio,
there seem to be a very robust and powerful tool that is two vaccines,
one injected,
we'll come back to that and the other oral,
the polio vaccines.
But as we speak,
the global eradication program has run into serious and unexpected pro
difficulties.
After it was originally launched in 1988 it went from success to success and
seem to be poised for successful eradication if perhaps not by its original
timetable of 2000 well then perhaps just a little bit later,
but in 2003 major difficulties over took the campaign and we'll come back to
those.
And now the campaign is a decade behind schedule and the elusive goal of global
eradication seems to be receding rather than becoming closer.
It's stalled particularly in for endemic countries,
India,
Afghanistan,
Pakistan and Nigeria,
and even spread particularly from Nigeria for an a to an array of other
countries.
So the question is whether this stalling is temporary and for contingent reasons
likely to be overcome or it was eradication on the smallpox model,
a mirage from the start,
and this can be personified in a major debate between two leading figures in
international public health.
One is Bruce Aylward,
who's the director general of the global public,
uh,
polio eradication initiative.
He is a great optimist and says that the problem is simply a matter of pressing
harder when difficulties emerge and he envisages eradication in short order.
Then there's da Henderson and he was the former director of the successful
smallpox eradication program and he was the director of polio eradication in the
region of the Americas.
Originally he was a very enthusiastic eradicator,
but now he's come around to the view instead that eradication was a mistaken
concept from the start that it will simply never work with polio,
which is totally unlike smallpox this morning.
Fortunately,
we don't need to make a decision and hopefully air ward will be successful.
But I do think we need to understand how difficult the eradication of a disease
actually is and to remember how exceptional smallpox is as a case.
Polio reminds us that small smallpox was an outlier rather than the norm.
Furthermore,
the polio problem is intellectually interesting and we ought to understand it in
order to comprehend tomorrow's press reports on why eradication perhaps didn't
succeed.
If that's the outcome.
I don't want to make a prediction because I'm mindful of that great sage,
a Yogi Berra who had an a saying that never predict the,
I'll make a prediction,
especially if it's about the future.
So in any case,
um,
we don't know whether polio will be eradicated or not.
I tend to be a skeptic,
but I really hope I'm wrong.
The polio virus has three types,
polio,
one,
two,
and three,
and it enters the body via the mouth,
uh,
perhaps through contaminated food or water or an unsanitary conditions with
direct contact with stools or with the secretions from the throat of a patient.
The virus then settles in the intestinal track and it multiplies there and
that's a picture of the polio virus.
After an incubation period of one to five days,
it then settles in lymphatic tissue along the intestines and in the lymph nodes.
Now normally the virus does no appreciable harm in the digestive tract producing
nothing more than some swollen lymph nodes and depart from that,
the infection can be totally asymptomatic.
In some cases it leads to minor symptoms.
These are brief such as a mild fever and other symptoms that would make you
think of it's seasonal influenza,
headache,
nausea,
vomiting.
Then the patient recovers with nothing more occurring and that's true.
Then of the vast majority of cases that end in that way,
and indeed in the historical literature,
this was termed a board of poliomyelitis because the infection progressed no
further,
but in about 1% or so of cases,
there's something much more serious that occurs,
which is the involvement of the central nervous system and that's where the
disease,
if it becomes so established,
does it serious damage.
It destroys nerves,
especially in the spinal cord and the brain.
There's a,
let me show you a rather a schematic rather scary picture of the polio virus
attacking a nerve cell.
When this occurs.
The results are severe pain,
weakness in the muscles and then paralysis and the paralysis can be one leg,
both legs,
the arms and the respiratory system.
The paralysis also is normally irreversible and often leads to very severe
deformity or maiming of the affected limbs.
If the muscles involved are those of the respiratory system,
the result can be respiratory paralysis and death.
Let me show you some of images of um,
the work of poliomyelitis.
This is a picture from the 1950s of a child in rehabilitation with paralyzed
legs,
braces and calipers or,
um,
we can see this is a poster of the campaign against poliomyelitis
or more.
This is the iron lung that was used to save the lives of those who had
respiratory paralysis.
And we can see another iron lung with the child inside.
And a terrible picture of that was all too common in the 30s,
forties and 50s,
which is a whole ward of children in iron lungs.
So this really was a terrible and cataclysmic disease and it's severe form.
Now what about the history?
Poliomyelitis was used to be called infantile paralysis until the 1890s it was
regarded as a minor medical and public health issue,
so it really exploded onto the world as a major public health and medical
problem only in the 1890s that's not to say that polio was an emerging disease
of the 1890s but I'm going to say that something new happened that trends formed
awareness of the disease.
It was thought then originally to be an exotic,
an unimportant,
endemic disease of early childhood.
But something happened in the 1890s and polio began to appear as something
different,
especially in the western industrial world.
It began to appear as a variable,
an epidemic disease.
It struck older groups of people,
adolescence and grownups,
as well as infants and in it's wake it less clusters of dead and paralyzed
victims.
The first substantial epidemics ever recorded struck Scandinavia,
Sweden in the 1890s in this country,
Vermont in 1894 Scandinavia again in 1905 New York in 1907 Vienna in 1908 and
the northeast of the United States,
and a devastating epidemic in 1916 after that,
epidemics of polio became a recurring and terrifying feature of the warm months
of the industrial west in the US.
For example,
polio struck with ever increasing fury reaching a peak of ferocity in the years
1950 to 1954 and by that time it had taken over from tuberculosis as the most
feared disease of the era.
Well,
what happened in here?
I think we ought to be careful.
Let's avoid an error that misled epidemiologists and public health officials at
least until World War II and then sometimes has misled ms medical historian
since then.
The mistake was to think that polio was in some simple way,
a disease of the affluent industrial nations of the clean and the prosperous
within them.
In reality.
Polio virus,
as we know,
is transmitted by the oral fecal route and it was ubiquitous in human
populations across the globe,
but hygienic advances transformed its epidemiology.
The sanitary bulwarks of the modern industrial state prevented children from
encountering the virus during infancy and early childhood and therefore they
failed to build an acquired immunity to the disease.
As a result,
the numbers of susceptible people in populations began to accumulate and that
provided the basis for periodic large scale epidemics that struck at later ages.
There was a distinguished Yale epidemiologists named John Paul who was very
active in the middle decades of the 20th century in dealing with poliomyelitis,
and he argued that the disease should no longer be called infantile paralysis
under the circumstances.
He said that term should be replaced with the phrase modern polio and modern
polio,
as he called.
It,
demonstrated a strong predilection for relatively prosperous,
older children,
adolescents and adults,
and it did so in the economically advanced nations of the world,
northern Europe,
North America,
Australia,
New Zealand,
polio.
In this sense what John Paul called modern polio seem to be,
if we could toy with the phrase that's all too familiar to you by now,
it seemed to be a kind of social disease in reverse.
That is,
it seemed to cause epidemics among the clean,
the wealthy and the suburban.
And so polio became a highly visible epidemic disease that terrified because it
was so visible because there was no cure and because everyone seemed to be
vulnerable while the disease itself left in its wig after each visitation,
thousands of people who were maimed and crippled as well as the dead.
But the reality was a little different.
Although epidemic,
modern poliomyelitis increased the pace of its ravages in the Western world.
Proof sooner emerged that polio also imposed an unnoticed but equally heavy
tribute of suffering and the resource poor tropical world.
In other words,
this was an illusion that it was only afflicting the industrial clean world.
This caused enormous surprise.
The prevailing dogma was that poliomyelitis was an affliction of modernity and
sanitation and was of negligible concern in the developing world.
But World War Two because to shock,
suddenly there was the experience of non-immune us British,
Australian troops stationed in places like Egypt or the Pacific and they're
against all expectations,
significant numbers of them contracted poliomyelitis
and then this disturbing finding,
which confirmed by evidence from Ciro logical examinations from rectal swabs,
from laboratory analysis of the Microbio bounty in third world sewers and by
lameness surveys that is actually counting people who are afflicted with
paralysis and places like India.
And the evidence confirm that paralytic poliomyelitis in the tropics,
which actually greater than in the developed world at its height,
but that it was unnoticed.
And why was it not notice?
It was not noticed in part because physicians and public health officials hadn't
long taught not to expect it.
Yeah,
everyone close the rise.
It was also true because the impoverished children of the tropical world had so
little access to medical care that they simply weren't seen.
They were invisible
because the illnesses of the poor were regarded as unremarkable.
And because the poor themselves fatalistically expected that their children
would suffer and die and disproportionate numbers.
So meanwhile,
maimed and paralyzed children grew up in the tropical world to join the ranks of
beggars in the streets of Jakarta,
Cairo,
and Lagos.
Well,
the polio virus was discovered in 1908 by Carl Lawn Steiner,
who's on your handout.
But thereafter,
the natural history of the disease remains shrouded in mystery.
Still in 1950 the mode of transmission and the portal of entry of the virus into
the body.
We're unknown as was the issue of whether polio virus existed in a single strain
or ends or stereotype or in multiple ones.
Was there one type or many?
Similarly,
the immune mechanisms of the body,
we're not understood.
And in fact,
a critical mistake was made
and this mistake misled the public health community.
We're searchers and medical science for a long period from the 1920s or so down
to the 1950s and this was to assume that the course of the disease in human
beings was the same as that in monkeys and other words,
there was an extrapolation from the laboratory to human beings.
And these,
this mistake had a number of corollaries.
It meant that it was assumed that the portal of entry of the virus was the nose
rather than the digestive tract.
It was assumed that the disease primarily attack the central nervous system and
the virus made its way from the nose to the spinal cord and the brain via the
nervous system.
Well,
in terms of public health and the possibility of vaccine development,
these conclusions were entirely counterproductive because they lead to a
corollary.
The corollary was at since the disease spread via the nervous system rather than
the bloodstream,
there was no opportunity for antibodies to mount a defense and therefore no
possibility for developing a vaccine.
Then we have enormous campaign of research and public health against this
increasingly feared and terrible disease.
And this was with the foundation of the national foundation of infantile
paralysis.
And uh,
it's spawned the march of dimes campaign,
which collected enormous amounts of money devoted to research and also to the
care and rehabilitation of the victims of poliomyelitis.
Let me just show you some images of the collecting the funds in the 19,
uh,
middle decades of the 20th century or a celebrity's took part.
This is Elvis Presley.
I'm campaigning for the march of dimes or the,
you can see Elvis again,
um,
there.
Um,
and most importantly,
uh,
one of the most famous,
probably the most famous of all polio victims was President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt who established the,
was the leading figure in the establishment of this foundation and the march of
dimes and also another for rehabilitation center in warm springs,
Georgia.
Let me just remind you that Fdr was in fact himself a victim of polio who is
paralyzed.
Well,
in 1948,
a major discovery was made by three men who worked together as a team and shared
the Nobel prize amongst themselves.
They,
these were John Anders,
Thomas Weller and Frederick Robins,
and they discovered that the polio virus could be cultured in vitro,
in non nervous human tissue.
Now,
why was not discovery critical?
Well,
first it meant that the cost of research plummeted because you didn't need to
have live monkeys to take care of in order to do experiments with the virus.
It led soon to the discovery that the digestive tract,
rather than the nose was the portal of entry.
And it led to the discovery of a phase in which antibodies could attack the
virus in the bloodstream.
And it led to the discovery that polio virus exists in three different
serotypes,
polio virus one polio virus too,
and polio virus three.
And it was these discoveries that made possible the development of successful
development of a vaccine.
And this duly occurred in two major forms.
And this was a momentous development.
The first was by Jonas Salk and that was an activated injectable vaccine tested
in 1904 and administered successfully on mass in 1955.
And Jonas Salk became a national hero and celebrity,
um,
for this on the cover of Time magazine.
Everyone talked about him and indeed he was later to save himself that he didn't
need the Nobel prize because he was much more famous than the price itself.
Okay.
Second was another vaccine,
a competitor,
if you like,
which was alive oral polio vaccine developed by Albert Sabin and tested in 1959
and 60 and administered on mass in the 1960s.
Now,
both of these developments were funded by the national foundation for infantile
paralysis.
You can see the role of the march of dimes and leading to medical discoveries
almost immediately after the development of these two vaccines.
The goal of eradication was taken up as an objective
in the 1950s already.
Albert Sabin,
for example,
made around education and article of faith.
He said,
the goal and I'm quoting,
is to completely eradicate poliomyelitis,
to eliminate it,
to make it disappear,
to achieve ultimate eradication.
Well,
a major question was,
which vaccine should the campaign be based on?
Socks,
IPV.
That is the injectable inactivated vaccine.
Let me try to,
whoops,
uh,
fix this in your mind.
This is a picture of Jonas Salk and as you can see,
he's holding a,
about to vaccinate someone with his injectable inactivated virus.
And here we can see him at work.
This is how Jonah Salk's vaccine operates with a syringe.
It had a number of drawbacks.
It was an effective,
um,
uh,
public health measure and led to a robust immunity,
but it was administered by injection.
And in terms of being a worldwide public health tool,
it required qualified vaccinators and not made it too complicated and expensive
for a worldwide campaign,
especially in third world countries.
And since it was a killed vaccine killed by Formaldehyde,
it would stimulate the production of antibodies,
but it wouldn't cause what was termed mucosal immunity directly in the human
gut.
Then there was the alternative,
which was developed by Albert Sabin,
which was the attenuated live virus.
This Hud,
it was administered initially on sugar cubes that were,
uh,
a couple of drops put on them and then people down them,
especially children or else it was a pink liquid that was simply dropped with a
dropper into your,
down her throat and not could be administered at a fraction of the cost,
as I said,
on sugar cubes or as a liquid.
And it,
the only skilled that was required of the vaccinator was the ability to count to
two because you drop two drops into the throat and that's the,
it took half an hour to train a vaccinator using Albert Saban's oral vaccine.
But equally importantly,
the oral polio virus,
because a virus to be shed from the intestine into the environment that is,
it took root and flourish in the god of the people of the vaccine knees.
And as they shed,
they would spread,
ah,
that is the virus causing an asymptomatic and harmless infection in the guts of
whole communities.
Thereby you would raise the herd immunity even if people who weren't vaccinated.
So you could miss people with Saban's vaccine and still reach entirely entire
communities.
So that was the vaccine than major new tool with its two different forms,
socks,
injectable vaccine,
and Sabins oral vaccine.
But what the campaign relied upon was something in addition to the new
scientific tools,
and this was a new operational campaign strategy.
And the campaign strategy interestingly,
was first devised in Fidel Castro's Cuba.
And the campaign strategy provided a context in which oral polio vaccine could
be maximally effective.
This was taken up in,
was called,
uh,
the tool of national immunization days.
Let's remember how they started.
Instead of limiting immunization to those who receive routine vaccinations from
their physicians.
The national immunization days took,
is it axiomatic that there was very limited access to medical care?
And so the idea was to not bring patients to the vaccinators but to take vaccine
to the people.
So in 1962 in Cuba,
the grass root organizations of Castro's revolution,
which recalled committees for the defense of the revolution,
carried out house to house surveys to locate every child on the island of Cuba.
And then vaccinators made a return visit to vaccinate every child who'd been
located.
This procedure morphed in the United States into what were called Sabin Oral
Sundays,
beginning at Tucson or is Arizona.
And as you can imagine,
these Sabin Oral Sundays weren't sponsored by committees for the defense of the
revolution,
but rather by local and county chapters of the Ama and its members volunteered
their services alongside those of local pharmacists,
county health officials,
nurses,
school teachers,
clergyman,
the local press and housewives.
And the vaccine was administered in school buildings.
This campaign thus structured with the new tool of vaccine and the new
organizational strategy of national immunization days successfully around a
catered smallpox first in the United States and then in the Americas in 1988 the
World Health Organization then launched the global polio eradication in
initiative.
At the outset,
it was supported in particular by what was the equivalent of the gates
foundation of its time and that is the resources and international structure of
the 32,000 clubs worldwide of Rotary International,
which was an Ngo,
as I said,
somewhat equivalent and it's time to the gates foundation of our own day.
The campaign also enjoyed the support of the CDC of international agencies like
the g eight as it was then.
It's no longer that it's expanded the African Union,
various national governments and an army of vaccinators.
From the beginning,
the global polio eradication initiative adopted the strategy of combining
Saban's oral polio vaccine with Cuba's operational device of community wide
immunization days.
The goal was to provide the most susceptible populations on earth,
small children worldwide,
every child on the planet to be vaccinated with at least two doses of oral polio
vaccine.
Now let's remember what a Gargantuan effort this actually was.
National Immunization Days were extraordinary events that necessitated the
participation of 10 million people in their organization.
Take the example of India where the national immunization days became the
largest single public health events in history when as many as 93 million
children were vaccinated on single days.
Well 19 oh 88 to 2003 the campaign made huge progress.
In 1988 the World Health Organization estimated that were there were 350,000
cases worldwide of paralysis from polio and it believed the disease to be
endemic in 125 countries.
In 1988 itself,
transmission was halted in Europe in 1991 it was halted in the Americas in 1997
in the Pacific region and in 2001 there was a world record with a low of 483
recorded cases of paralysis in just for endemic countries.
India,
Pakistan,
Afghanistan,
and Nigeria.
Let me show you a map of,
and this is 2008,
as you can see,
and the countries in red are,
those were,
uh,
polio is now endemic and the ones in yellow are places that it spread to from
those endemic countries in 2008.
Well,
there was a set back in 2003 and what did that indicate already?
Vanquished in the industrial world,
poliomyelitis in 2003 remained and dem only in some of the most unsanitary
poverty stricken and insecure places on the planet.
This is one reason that it's a mockery to think of poliomyelitis as a disease of
the affluent and the clean polio.
Maya Litas had been driven back
to the war torn and remote areas of Pakistan to Muslim dominated states of
northern Nigeria,
northern sinned in Pakistan and the states of Bihar and [inaudible] progress in
India.
Now the Moslem states of Nigeria and especially Cano as we'll talk about in the
moment where the most striking cases there in northern Nigeria,
the campaign was actually halted by a boycott,
an organized boycott for 13 months.
As a result in Nigeria,
the disease flared up causing hundreds of cases of acute paralysis and
alarmingly,
it's spread from Nigeria widely causing outbreaks of paralysis in 18 countries
in west and central Africa that had previously been pronounced polio free.
Well,
what were the problems that emerged in 2003 I'm going to say that they were
operational,
religious,
political and biological.
Operationally you can see the problems and that would emerge and a place like
Afghanistan and why that would be a recalcitrant place for public health
officials to attempt to eradicate a disease as entrenched as polio,
war and lack of security made vaccination campaigns dangerous and sometimes
impossible.
But let's look for a moment at a different place.
And this is a map of Nigeria.
If you imagine the country and that knots,
the state,
I want to talk about the state of Kano in northern Nigeria.
There we see a problem of that's political and religious
Muslim leaders in Kano and that's in a country,
the government of Nigeria is Christian dominated.
This states of northern Nigeria,
however,
are Muslim.
And they were suspicious in northern Nigeria about western intentions,
especially after the launching of war in Afghanistan and Iraq.
And people began to preach religious leaders that Oreo oral polio vaccine,
these drops,
we're not a measure of public health,
but instead a sinister plot to sterilize Muslim children by poisoning them so
that as long would recede from the earth and Christianity could replace it.
And this whole thinking was,
um,
ramped up by the issue raised by the pharmaceutical giant Pfizer,
which had conducted unethical testing in Nigeria in a way that inflamed public
opinion especially and led to a major lawsuit against the company.
Furthermore,
since the traditional Dogma about poliomyelitis hell did,
it was an insignificant public health problem in the tropical world.
It was difficult for many to understand why the international community was so
intent on trying to rid Nigeria of polio.
The Nigerians themselves regarded other diseases as much greater causes of death
and suffering.
Why was the international community not concentrated on dealing with malaria,
tuberculosis,
and HIV AIDS?
Why all this attention to polio that seem to them a relatively minor problem.
And the emir of Kano was unable to discern benign intentions.
Also,
when it transpired that industrial predominantly Christian nations,
we're vaccinating their own populations instead with salk's vaccine.
That is the IPV,
while insisting that Nigerians received the oral vaccine,
why on earth was dot.
Finally,
opposition to the vaccination campaign promoted by the Christian dominated
federal government of Nigeria served as a proxy for sectional political and
religious discontents and the minority northern stays.
So the result was a boycott of the anti polio campaign and it lasted until 2004
at which time Moslem operated laboratories in Indonesia agreed to supply
vaccines to Nigeria and other Muslim operated laboratories in India analyze the
vaccine previously supplied to Kano and found it to be harmless,
at which point prominent Muslim leaders around the world press there
co-religionists in Nigeria to support the international effort.
But by then considerable harm had been done to the campaign was not clear
either.
That large numbers of Muslim parents would ever again allow their children to be
immunized or that the spread of the virus beyond Nigerian borders was something
that could be reversed.
So let's say that deals then with political and religious obstacles,
then there are were biological ones.
And to illustrate those,
let me go somewhere else and this is we'll tarp progress in a Muslim dominated
state in India.
And again,
you see there the issue of Muslims suspicions and resistance to vaccination,
but I want to turn from those.
Imagine that all of that going on.
But I'd like to look at some biological issues that emerged in places like this.
The first was whether a polio turned out to be more complicated than smallpox
because smallpox had only one serotype.
Polio virus has types one,
two and three and there's no crossover immunity from one to the other.
So it was a more complicated disease than smallpox.
That was a first problem.
And this emerged in the form of what kind of vaccine you use.
One that's monovalent attacking,
developing resistance against only one type of polio virus or polyvalent.
Should it be a tried to immunize you at once against one,
two oral three times?
It turned out that polyvalent vaccines for complicated reasons weren't so
effective.
Yeah.
Another was a problem of monitoring and surveillance.
Unlike smallpox,
vast majority of polio cases,
we're in a symptomatic and then there was a problem called the uh,
interference.
Children were found to be vaccinated 20 and 25 times and still not to have
developed an immunity to polio.
Okay.
Why was that?
It turned out that an unsanitary tropical conditions,
the intestinal flora of other viruses,
particularly enteroviruses in the Senate,
in the digestive tract,
could be so dense that the polio virus and the vaccine would be unable to
establish an infection and therefore an immune response.
There were other problems that emerged in these turbulent years after 2003
turbulent for the Global Publi oh eradication initiative,
one was that live viruses,
this Sabin polio virus,
remember,
it's a live vaccine.
It was unlike the smallpox vaccine.
The smallpox vaccine,
as you know,
was a vaccine from cow pox that had a crossover immunity to small pox and cow
pox is not a serious human disease.
Okay.
With polio instead what's administered through the oral vaccine is a live virus
and attenuated.
Strange,
yes,
but it still is the live virus and therefore there is always the possibility of
the virus mutating and reverting to a very on that form and this indeed happened
causing outbreaks of what's called vaccine associated paralytic polio.
This possibility wasn't just theoretical,
it happened in the Philippines,
in Madagascar,
in China and in Indonesia,
reversing progress against the disease outbreaks or that kind of occasion to
quip the quip that it was impossible to eradicate polio without the oral polio
vaccine,
but it was also impossible to eradicate polio with it because the vaccine itself
led to outbreaks of polio.
So vaccine associated polio virus implied something serious that the campaign
against poliomyelitis could have no logical end point because it would always be
necessary to immunize populations against epidemics that could be initiated by
the vaccine itself.
A very paradoxical situation and the difficulty is all the more intractable
because people with immunodeficiency disorders can continue to shed the virus
for as long as 10 years or more.
So if the campaign were ever allowed to lapse,
the accumulation of non unimmunized susceptibles could result in devastating
virgin soil epidemics among those who had no immunity.
So for this reason,
critics have argued that the who campaign involved a semantic trick with the
word eradication.
Traditionally around occasion had always implied the cessation of the need to
maintain public protective public health policies.
But vaccine associated polio,
paralytic polio meant that planners for this campaign would have to continue
immunization indefinitely.
The traditional criterion that eradication implied,
the end of prophylactic measures was quietly drunk and then their,
their problems about certification and eradication.
Polio virus is notorious for being silent and undetected and its circulation at
the other end of the spectrum from smallpox.
So how would you be able to actually confirm that there were no more cases?
And it's also true that another problem that pole symptoms of paralytic acute
flaccid
paralysis can be caused by other conditions.
There.
On your handout,
I won't mention them because I'm rapidly running out of time,
but in my last 30 seconds,
I would say that the history of Global Polio Eradication Initiative demonstrates
that the original optimistic belief that polio like smallpox can be rounded
readily eradicated by vaccination was misplaced.
Smallpox is exceptionally vulnerable to a top.
It has no animal reservoirs,
no range of Syrah types that confer no crossover immunity.
It's symptoms are almost always memorable and florid.
For the software,
it gives rise and survivors to a lasting immunity and the vaccine used to
attacked.
It is effective after a single effort.
Polio is a far more formidable enemy that reminds us that the original
eradication is perspective may be illusory.
The human condition is to be surrounded by near infinity of infectious,
constantly evolving microbes.
Occasional final victories are possible,
but they should be celebrated as exceptions rather than regarded as successive
steps to a garden free Eden,
the normal state is one of vigilance to minimize harm and achieve control.
Polio seems to me unlikely soon to follow smallpox by becoming the second
infectious disease ever to be eradicated.
That would be,
uh,
if I had time,
I talk more about it,
but I don't.
So let's stop there.
And I don't want to make a prediction,
but I think we need to see how complex eradication actually is.
And polio isn't like smallpox and many other diseases aren't.